hey sarah hey there morgan how are you
i am great i have to tell you i need a
season two in my life
i don't know if i can handle it i love
this series so much
oh well you're not the only one i do too
i need to know what happened
to that last scene right the last words
oh so perfect um
so i was talking to you create your
creator stacy and she was just saying
how much you put yourself on camera for
this how much you wanted the role of
billy
why were you so passionate about this
series well i
you know i read the script and you know
not only
is was the dialogue i thought something
that it this kind of material does not
come around very often
um it was so well written and some of
the dialogue felt like it was ripped out
of the pages of my own heart
you know i felt like i was saying some
of these things in my own life at times
so i just felt such a personal
connection to her but
she was just dynamite in a box you know
i mean it was just
she was she was beautiful she was messy
she was vulnerable
she got to be sexy and funny and an
awesome mom
and i just felt like as an actress it
was almost like a one-woman show to be
able to show all those different colors
um yeah i and you know and then i could
relate there was a lot about her that i
could relate i'm a mother of three
myself and
i feel like motherhood is complex it's
messy um but you can be a really great
mom and also still wonder about the
choices that you made
yeah no absolutely there are so many
amazing sex scenes in this as well
was it refreshing to you to have a
series that not only is directed by
women
uh those things are are are written
primarily by women was it refreshing to
read those scenes
yes i mean a lot of times you know you
have sex scenes
um that focus on women and they're
written directed
by men and this time we were really able
to flip that on its head you know not
only did we have
do we have a female show runner but
every episode was directed by a woman
and you know we were able to see it all
through the female point of view the
camera was lingering on the men's bodies
just as long if not a little bit longer
than what it was lingering on my body
and it was just super refreshing you
know to be able to
flip that and then also to show that
women can
get off in a lot of different positions
not just the missionary one
so hopefully there's a bit of education
that comes around with this too
it's about time absolutely it is about
time i agree
and you know for you it's wonderful
reading these scenes but
what was it like dealing with the
physicality of this series i mean you
and adam have fantastic chemistry
oh thank you so much you know yeah it
was
it was challenging i mean you know
between the amount of newt scenes that i
had to do in sex scenes that i had to do
you know not just with mike and with
adam but uh
you know the sex montage i mean there
were like four or five
random not random obviously but you know
but yeah
find the main cast that i had to i had
to have sex with and
and it was definitely challenging
between that and the
emotionally you know the vulnerable
scenes that i had to do
uh i became a big prayer i prayed a lot
for everything every night dear god
please let me hit my mark
and do a good job please don't let like
thank you amen
it was a challenge and you know it's
like i
i hope it all came together because it
was
it was uh yeah it was challenging well
like i said i was like obsessed with
this year's you know you watch a show
and you watch the first few episodes
you're like yeah okay but then i was
like
i need to watch the whole thing now
so no it's so amazing i also want to
talk to you i'm so excited to see you in
black adam have you guys started
shooting yet
yes we've been shooting since march um
yeah we've been shooting since march and
i don't know if we're
anywhere near being done
it's definitely a new beast being a part
of you know
the the dc world and the superhero
universe and stuff it's very different
oh i can only imagine uh are you hitting
up the gym like dwayne johnson's doing
like dwayne johnson style
i leave that to him he's kind of got
that covered he works out
me and him that's amazing well look
there's so many of these movies out
there which is great but what are you
excited specifically about this one
uh about black adam yeah um
you know i'm excited to be a part of
something my kids can watch
and my family doesn't you know my
brother can actually sit there with
you know both eyes open instead of one
eye closed
that's amazing i was going to say yeah
that's not going to add him and he's
like i don't want my mom to see this
turn away yeah awesome thank you so much
really appreciate it congrats on the
series
thank you so much morgan have a good day